my name is Bowden Kelly I worked at
Microsoft I'm a program manager working
on JavaScript tools including typescript
nodejs and other tooling support in
Visual Studio and Visual Studio code but
today we're looking at specifically how
to get you from 0 to 60 with typescript
in node.js we only have 25 minutes so
we're gonna go kind of fast it'll be
very demo driven if you have questions
hold them to the end and I'll try to get
them in time if you get nothing else
from this session I want you to
understand why typescript is worth your
time you know there's a lot of tools out
there there's a lot of technologies
these days for a JavaScript developer to
consider and if you take nothing else
away you should understand why why
typescript what does it aim to do and
we'll get to that right off the bat I'm
also going to show you how to get
productive fast in whatever environment
you're currently in and then finally I'm
going to show you just a little bit of
typescript in action so why typescript
we think it's pretty simple
we believe that developers should be
able to focus on creating amazing things
and creating is bold here because that's
what we all aim to do with code you know
code is just a tool at the end of the
day to help us build services and
products and experiences to truly why
our users but in reality that's not
really how we spend our time if you take
every activity you do on a week-to-week
basis and your development cycles they
can fall into three broad categories
understanding code this is you know
reading the existing code looking up
documentation finding bugs maintaining
existing code so this includes
refactoring and preparing for new
features and fixing those bugs that you
know already exist and then finally
finally after you've done all of those
things if you've paid all that tax you
can actually write new code and deliver
new experiences we found with javascript
in particular the larger your code base
grows the more complicated it gets and
the harder it gets to focus on creation
as anyone familiar with Monaco
how about vias code so Monaco is where
vias code started the idea was we wanted
to take an editor environment and put it
in the browser and so as such this was
all written in JavaScript and we found
that as this code base hit three hundred
four hundred four thousand lines of code
it became really hard to focus on
creation and we actually kind of
measured we said how long are we
spending on each of these buckets and
what we found is a vast
our time was just trying to understand
what our code was even doing then we
spent about 25 percent of our time
maintaining and then finally five
percent or two hours and a 40-hour
workweek actually trying to build that
that editor in the browser and we said
you know this this is not this is not
good enough we can definitely do better
what would it take what if we could take
this split and just build some tools
such that minor savings from
understanding and maintenance could add
to creation time instead and what would
that tool look like and it was chasing
that idea that we created typescript now
what exactly is typescript the technical
definition is an optionally type
superset of JavaScript that compiles to
plain JavaScript but I've always found
it easier just to show rather than tell
so here we are in a JavaScript file this
is a random javascript file that we took
out of a random project and to get
started with typescript to see what
typescript does all we're gonna do is
add a single comment and it's going to
be TS check at the top of our file and
what this is gonna do is it's gonna flag
this in vs code and this is you know vs
code by the way if you're unfamiliar you
should check it out it's a great editor
but if you just put TS check at the top
it's gonna flag this file and say hey I
want you go type check this JavaScript
for me you know do nothing else just run
the typescript type checker and tell me
if anything looks off and right off the
bat you see we have some red squiggles
so this is actually not even part of the
demo but z object I guess that's a typo
my bad but a type so it's gonna look at
all these things and see what makes
sense or what doesn't make sense and in
this case the Z object they don't know
what that is and so they flag it and in
fact it was a typo it was a mistake so
we can delete that out we could look at
the next mistake argument of type this
string literal value in read-only is not
assignable to the parameter property
descriptor and so what's happening here
is javascript has types it is
dynamically typed so they can change and
they're not necessarily enforced ever
but they do have types types exist under
the scenes and that's what typescript
looking at and so if we look at this
defined property method we can see that
there are in fact types that javascript
expects at runtime and if we look at
this property descriptor there are a
limited set of options that you can pass
through and
anything that isn't in this set this is
going to get ignored by JavaScript at
runtime it doesn't care right and so
we're gonna look at this we're C
configurable and numerable value and
writable and we can see that back in our
code we used read-only so probably what
we intended was to say writable false or
actually true and you see our error goes
away but what would I have been a
runtime again if I pass in read-only
into this method it's gonna look at it
it's going to see that it doesn't match
what's expecting that's gonna pretend
like it never saw anything and so now
you have a misconfigured object your
method it may be behaving in a way that
you didn't expect and you don't even
have an error to point you to the right
direction where where your code went
wrong and that's what typescript does it
points you in the right direction here
we have another mistake where we see
operator greater than cannot be applied
to some function and a number if we look
at ship weight sure enough it's a
function that returns the parse int of
some text so probably what we intended
to do was call this function but we
didn't write and this is this is a
common mistake I've done this thousands
of times but you won't catch this until
runtime and in fact that runtime what's
going to happen when you compare a
function and a number it's false it's
not an error it's not true it's false
and so this code is going to be
misbehaving you will never find that
you're you know shipping weight is over
a hundred it will always return false
and you'll have no idea why your codes
misbehaving typescript can help you save
you from these little mistakes but this
is just JavaScript right we haven't done
anything to change what's going on here
typescript is just looking at your
existing JavaScript because typescript
is a superset of JavaScript but what
else can we do with typescript well we
can start adding types in this function
we have an email address parameter and
typescript saying this is an inny and so
right now it doesn't know anything about
this parameter but we can tell it we can
say hey I've got this comment here that
says it can be a string or a string
array so I'm going to use a J's comment
because again we're still in a j-style
I'm going to say this is a string or a
string array and now typescript knows
from this J's comment that we want this
to be a string or a string array and now
I can continue type checking the rest of
your code with this assumption that this
is what you're saying it is and here we
find a
mistake where we have misspelled trim
because Trin is not a function off of
email address and so basically what
you're seeing here is typescript is just
JavaScript typescript is just additional
tools to help you write better
JavaScript to take care of the little
mistakes and let you focus on what
you're actually trying to build and so
where are you supposed to take away from
that quick demo really you can start
using type checking JavaScript today
it's very simple in vs code all you have
to do is out of comment to the top of
your file using TS check will get you
started fast you don't have to deal with
configuration you don't have to deal
with config files or build set ups all
you have to do is add that comment and
then you can slowly start adding jsoc
comments with types in them to
experiment with what types would be like
what is it like to work with a type
system you don't have to jump in all at
once so you get it you see you can add a
type system type checking to JavaScript
but does it really work a lot of people
think that you know I'm fine without
type checking it wouldn't really help me
that much
well for the skeptics out there there
has been a empirical research on this
where they took 400 code bases on github
they looked at bugs that made it into
production and then they went back and
applied both slow and typescript to
those code bases to see if a compile
time type checker would have prevented
that bug from ever making it to
production and they found that 15% of
those 400 bugs would have never made it
into production and been caught by a
type checker and so it works type
systems work so so you saw how we can
start type checking JavaScript but type
scripts more than that typescript is a
superset and it really allows a lot more
features than you just saw and so to
show you how you can convert an entire
existing Express code base I'm gonna
take this simple app which is a basic
Express app it's actually a pared down
sample from a QuickStart and basically
it gives you a boilerplate for a node.js
Express application it's got some basic
templates it's got authentication using
passport you know I can login and it's
really just a starting point you know
many people use these to get started
with their applications these days and
so this is what we're going to start
with and I'm going to convert this
JavaScript code base to typescript just
to show you how easy it is and some of
the things you get once you do and so as
you can see we've got a node modules
folder a node modules backup folder
because I'm very paranoid about having
internet during demos
you've got a source folder a lot of
JavaScript files in here and then your
basic config files and so the first
thing to do to get going with you know
the full-blown typescript is you need a
TS config and so I'm a type PFC in it
from the integrated terminal in vs code
and it's going to generate me a TS
config file and we're going to see in
this TS config file is a ton of options
right but these are all commented out
these are basically every option you
could pass into T as config with an
explanation of what it is and so it's
very useful for getting familiar with
what your options are but we already
know what we need and so I'm just going
to delete this and cut straight to the
chase we're targeting node so we can use
es6 commonjs is fine we want to use a
loud J s and what this is going to let
us do is pass both JavaScript and
typescript into the compiler and I'll
show you what that means in a second we
didn't want a out directory and we'll
call this disc for distribution and then
finally we want a module resolution to
be node and this is just going to tell
the types of compiler I'm in a node
application I'm targeting a node
environment you should do module
resolution in the same kind of way that
I would expect in node and the last
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
include my source file as you see here I
have a source directory and that will
basically set the route in which
typescript consumes source files and so
now when I run TSC which invokes the
typescript compiler you will see that I
made a mistake
oh you're right thank you so this is
just globbing pattern and I reversed
that on accident so we're going to run
it you're going to see we now have a
dist folder inside this disk folder is
the same thing we put in we just passed
in JavaScript files and we got out
JavaScript files and you'll notice these
are exactly the same which is good so we
can now convert we have our compiler set
up we can now convert our first file
from jazz to TS and once we've done this
we can now you know write typescript as
we would expect where we can add type
annotations inline to functions and then
when we call the function if we don't
pass in the correct type it will
complain right we are now in a type
script file a types of environment the
compiler is checking this by default now
but notice the rest of my files are
still JavaScript so I can now run TSC
again and it will take all of the
typescript files in this source file
convert them to JavaScript and we'll
take all of the JavaScript files and
just basically pass them through the
compiler and it will put them all in my
distribution folder so that I can still
run my app so now I can still do node
and this time we'll go from dist
and we'll put server and that's not it
and fire it up and you'll see that it is
in fact still working as we'd expect
nothing has changed so this is the part
where if you have a large project you
might want to go file by file one file
at a time convert it to typescript do
your work and make it the conversion in
a piecemeal fashion but because this is
a small project and there's only a
handful of files I'm just going to go
ahead and convert these all to TS just
so you can see what that conversions
going to be like and so we're gonna run
TSC again and this is where you start to
run into the first kind of friction from
converting right we're gonna get a
couple of errors and you see a bunch of
them or cannot read Eclair this block
scope variable passport right and
basically what's happening here is if we
go look at passport ts we can see we've
got squiggles on our imports and this is
a
kind of complicated subject if you dealt
with modules in JavaScript before you
know that it's a pretty deep rabbit hole
and so I'm not gonna go too in depth
here but basically this this code is
written and require using you know
common j/s what we need it to be is an
es6
so the typescript compiler can
understand it and then return it back to
commonjs and so to do that we can just
use this handy reg X that I have in this
sketchy unsaved notepad file and what
this reg X is going to do is it can take
all of our import statements and convert
them to the es6 import star syntax so
when i do that you'll see it highlights
all of my imports i can go ahead and
execute that and it's going to replace
them all in line and I now have import
star as passport from passport and you
see the types of compiler is now happy
the other thing I have to do is if I
change my imports I also got changed my
exports and so we'll do that real quick
- good make sure we don't change
anything in jQuery that would be bad and
all of our exports get changed as well
now this isn't a perfect conversion this
was just a real quick regex I wrote
right you know before this and so
there's a couple places where it doesn't
do exactly what we want for example when
we're trying to export our model we use
modules export instead of export equals
or exports equals rather and so we have
to go clean this up by hand but you
could write a much better you're ready
regex than I could and make this
actually work and so we're going to
switch this to export default user and
you'll see why we want a default in a
while and then we also need to switch
this module export to export app export
equals app there we go so now we're
going to go ahead and check our problems
list to see where our remaining problems
are and it looks like we've got one more
error again this is another module thing
because of the way expressed validator
exposes itself in in their module we
have to use a slightly separate syntax
for the
module this is pretty rare but Express
validator is the one that you'll
experience in a node project where you
have to say import Express validator
equals require instead of from Express
validator again kind of a nuisance but
it comes into this whole inherited
module problem that we have so now let's
look at some of the remaining errors we
have and so this one will tell us that
property ID does not exist on this type
which is an empty object and if we look
at this we can see that you know
serialized user has a full function body
and if we look at that this is actually
a DTS file that we have hiding in the
project and this is where I have to to
lie to you a little bit I went ahead and
downloaded all the DTS files for this
project ahead of time again for internet
reasons but basically what happens here
is if we go to our package JSON we can
get the type definitions for just about
every single node module by going to at
types which is basically a community
it's on github that just contributes all
of their own Taipings to a community and
we can download them by using the add
type scope on NPM and so when I say at
types / expression session I'm getting
the DTS file for express session and you
can see I have a number of DTS files
that I've gone ahead and grabbed and all
of these are imports that I use
somewhere in this project and what this
does is in my node modules folder you
will see I have an @ types folder and in
here I have a DTS file for every single
one of these which contains the types
which will let me type check the code
this is really great because this is
basically free value right typically
when you're using a type checker you
have to provide the types for them to
check when you use a DTS file someone
has already gone and done all of the
work of adding those types for you and
you just get to benefit from that labor
so that's great so we're looking at this
and we're saying okay well there's a
problem here ID does not exist on this
you know user but this is our user model
this is the thing that you know we
defined use for Mongoose right
and basically what we need to tell type
script here is this is
a little more specific than just an
empty object in fact it is a mongoose
document and so we can import document
sorry you can import from mongoose
document which is a type again that has
already been defined for us if we look
at that we can see this is a DTS file
again and someone has gone ahead and
defined all of the things that exist on
a mongoose document and now we can say
this user is actually of type document
and that that error will go away
but not all of the errors go away and if
we look at ok we have another problem
here where we're importing user
incorrectly if we right-click and go to
definition on this user we see we just
end up in this file but not on the
actual user we export and so the issue
in this case is because we use the
default export we have to alias the
import so we say default as user and
then we're all better
anyway it's back to our back to our user
model if we look at this user model
we'll add document here again and we'll
expect to resolve this error except in
this case it doesn't work and that's
because compare password is a method
that we added onto our user model in
Mongoose and so we've added this custom
method it doesn't exist
on the document and so we need some way
to extend document and say you know this
isn't just a document this is a user
document and so what you can do is you
can create a type in type script so
we'll export type user document and
we'll say that this is a mongoose
document and some additional stuff and
what this is is an intersection type
this ampersand basically says i have one
type that i want to start with and i
want to throw more stuff into it to
create some new type which we'll call
user document and so we'll add compare
password here
and we'll make it an innie just for now
and when we go back to our document and
we make this now a user document oh we
gotta import it first sorry wrong place
when we now make this a user document
you'll see that our error goes away and
indeed if we look at this user we can
see that we have the base document stuff
on it like ID for example but we also
have our function compare password which
is of type in E and so we can actually
do much better than this because when we
defined this model there was a bunch of
stuff in it right we have you know
profile which has a bunch of strings and
password and password token and so again
back to my sketchy notepad we can grab
the type and type out exactly what we
want this type to be it'll go ahead and
format this real quick and now when we
refer to it now that we've added you
know all of the properties that exist on
this type when we actually use it
we're in passport we can see that we
have access to all of those things so if
I look at profile we have profile and we
can see all of the properties that exist
inside profile and so again typescript
is just helping you here it's telling
you what your options are what's
available if you make a mistake and try
to you know do something that's not
there it's going to tell you this
property does not exist on this model
that you created and it's going to give
you basically the help you need to focus
on what you're trying to build let's see
last one this is also an import error
where we're importing user and this
needs to be a default and with that we
should be done we've now converted all
of our files to typescript we can run
TSC and see that it does compiled to
you are distributed folder and it comes
back clean there's no errors if we run
node on that server and we started up we
can see that our application still works
as we expect right but now we're in like
a fully typed environment we're not
fully typed yet we're in a type script
capable environment so we can start
adding types wherever we want and so
from here on out you can use typescript
or types when it's helpful and ignore
them when it's not and so if we go look
at user TS this controller for example
you can see that we have requests and
responses all throughout this file where
we don't have types yet and so if we
want to we can import from Express
request and response and now we can add
these types in line and so what this
does is if you look at you know before
we add it if I do request dot I get
nothing right our editor knows nothing
about this thing but as soon as I tell
it what it is and again we're taking
advantage of types that other users have
already defined for us if we look at
this we can see that there is really a
lot of work that has been done here that
we can just take advantage of right away
when we start using these things we now
get great help great tools great support
if we make mistakes the compiler is
going to catch it if we just want to you
know write code and see what the you
know functions do or their signatures do
you can get all of that right in your
editor and so you don't have to flip
back and forth between documentation you
don't have to spend your time trying to
figure out what those methods are that
you can call you can spend more time
actually doing the work you want to do
that looks like that's about all the
time I have I want to call out that this
is a tiny sample taken from a larger
sample if you go to Microsoft slash
typescript node starter this is a repo
that we maintain so that you can see
what a node and type script repository
looks like and look at other best
practices like testing and CI and
setting up vias code with tests
JSON and debugging configurations all of
that stuff lives in this repository we
don't have time to go over today but I
encourage you to check it out if you're
interested
final kind of kind of takeaways I
encourage you if you've never used the
type checker before download via skoda
throw at TS check at the top of your
file just to see what happens you may be
surprised and find that you have a
couple bugs lurking it also may be
totally clean the worst that could
happen is nothing right I also would
encourage you to think about adding
typescript to any of your current
workflows because it really works
anywhere you can lay it on top in about
what 10 minutes we just added it to an
Express application but you can really
add it to any kind of node project
you're using today and finally the point
of all of this whether it's using node
whether it's using typescript any of
these tools is to help you focus on
building cool stuff you know services
products experiences for customers and I
encourage you to think about that next
time you're working on a project how can
I be more productive we think typescript
in node can help you do that thank you
[Applause]